nous offrons des mesures ciblées pour
alléger l'inflation parce que c'est la
bonne chose à faire mais pendant que la
Banque du Canada lutte contre
l'inflation nous ne compliquerons par
son travail nous sommes compétitions et
nous sommes aussi responsables
[Musique]
d'équilibre qu'elle souhaitait accomplir
jeudi dernier aider de façon ciblée sans
alimenter l'inflation en laissant la
Banque du Canada faire son travail que
doit-on retenir de l'énoncé économique
de Christian Freeland voyons voir ce
qu'en pense mes collaborateurs
de midi info à ici première et
chroniqueur au torontoster et au
magazines d'actualité et Michel est
absent cette semaine c'est Hugo la
vallée qui jouait à nous c'est notre
nouvelle analyse au bureau parlementaire
de Québec félicitations Hugo bonjour à
vous trois
bonjour bonjour
je vais commencer avec vous qu'est-ce
que vous retenez vous dénoncez
économique de Madame féline puisque elle
a marqué est-ce que là
on a un peu l'impression que c'est un
énoncé de transition en parlant des
années on n'avait pas l'impression que
c'était vraiment une priorité pour le
gouvernement Trudeau le retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire on dépensait sans
trop compter il y a eu des signaux
peut-être justement d'un certain
resserrement au cours des dernières
semaines madame Freeland qui parle de
responsabilité fiscale on se rend compte
que justement à trop dépensé d'argent
ici comme ailleurs dans d'autres pays
aussi un contrecoup justement et en même
temps il y a un mouvement dans ce sens
là dans cette énoncé là mais quand même
quelques dépenses c'est quoi près de la
moitié là des nouveaux revenus qui sont
engagés dans de nouvelles dépenses donc
on voit qu'il y a une certaine
transition mais par contre il faut le
noter là il y a enfin une date de retour
à l'équilibre budgétaire potentiel elle
est lointaine beaucoup de choses qui a
le temps de changer évidemment d'ici là
mon on a l'impression que on a une
volonté d'envoyer ce signal là justement
donc d'essayer de prendre ce virage lors
d'une logique un peu plus dépensière
vers une certaine forme de rigueur
budgétaire peut-être un petit peu
d'influence de Monsieur Paulien
là-dedans je suis en train vraiment
sérieusement ouais on a l'impression que
les sondages il y en avait encore cette
semaine d'Abacus qui montrait
prochainement que les conservateurs sont
en avance sans les intentions de vote
c'est que plus ou moins d'importance
dans le moment mais que sur les grands
dossiers santé environnement les
libéraux sentiraient plutôt bien sur la
gestion de l'économie qui pourrait être
la question de l'une ils sont quand même
derrière les conservateurs et c'est une
vraie marche donc s'ils veulent faire
une campagne contre Pierre poliev c'est
sûr que la mise à jour budgétaire leur
permis d'installer dans le calendrier
une date au-delà de la prochaine
campagne fédérale en passant où ils
pourront dire si vous nous donnez un
autre mandat on va équilibrer le budget
en 27 28 je le sais pas si on va
équilibrer le budget à 27 28 si vous
voulez mon avis madame Freeland ne sait
pas non plus mais c'est loin d'être
certain qu'en dans une campagne fédérale
en 1920 en 2024 ou 25 on sera plus donc
ça permet au gouvernement fédéral de se
repositionner comme je suis une personne
qui s'intéresse aux choses élémentaire
je note que le gouvernement survit à la
mise à jour budgétaire c'est un
gouvernement minoritaire qui en a donc
dépensé assez pour que le NPD malgré
tout ce que Monsieur sing dit depuis
jeudi le MPD continue à appuyer le
gouvernement Justin Trudeau donc on est
bon sur ce front là jusqu'au budget du
printemps c'est vrai monsieur signe
toute la semaine il y avait que deux
mauvais mots à l'endroit de l'énoncé
économique pour finir par dire mais je
vais l'appuyer quand même alors
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous retenez
vous de l'exercice
qu'on appelle le strict minimum du côté
de Christian Freeland on n'avait pas
envie de sortir les feux d'artifice
entre autres parce qu'on avait déjà fait
une partie du travail avant c'est à dire
que doubler le crédit de tps à
l'occasion spéciale pour ceux qui ont la
difficulté à se loger ça c'est des gros
morceaux quand même ça avait été annoncé
adopté avant l'annoncé économique des
mesures qui commencent à peine à
distribuer les chèques sont envoyés là
au moment où on se parle donc de
rajouter une série de mesures plus
importante encore ça aurait été
peut-être un peu rapide donc on a fait
le strict minimum ce qui correct dans le
mesure où au moment donné on essaie de
contrôler l'inflation on sait pas à quel
point
la hausse est taux d'intérêt va vraiment
percuter l'économie canadienne c'est
toujours un retardement parfois on est
mieux de se garder un peu de munitions
ont regardé
garder en réserve certaines mesures
qu'on pourra annoncer là si jamais ça se
dégrade au début de la nouvelle année on
était pas obligé de tout faire lors de
cette énoncé économique là et je pense
que c'est correct
s'en vient normalement plus tard on peut
encore mettre de nouvelles mesures
là-dedans on a on va voir ce qui va se
passer oui chantant
et dans nouvelle mesure comprenez les
provinces qui ont écouté et regarder
tout ça nous on veut négocier une
nouvelle entente sur le financement de
la santé avant le prochain budget alors
vous entendez pas beaucoup de Premier
ministre de province dire elle a pas
assez dépenser cette semaine parce que
eux qui restent l'argent pour eux
effectivement d'ailleurs la conversation
sur la santé commence avec Monsieur
Duclos puis ces homologues cette semaine
justement on va reparler de santé on va
faire un saut à Québec je pense encore
des choses et libéraux les deux choses
de Madame anglaise ça va pas très bien
je vais vous faire entendre deux
extraits qui résument bien la semaine
qu'elle a eu puis ensuite je reviens
ça a été trop loin parce qu'on voit bien
les résultats on voit bien que ça a été
trop loin je pense que il faut le
reconnaître et dire ben on envoie un
message d'une main tendue moi j'ai une
main tendue à Marie-Claude apprend
clairement pas les bonnes décisions elle
est vraiment mal conseillé aussi le
Dominique Dominique n'a plus le
leadership pour être à la tête du Parti
libéral du Québec bon alors ça c'était
la semaine dernière on en avait parlé
madame madame Nicole ils avaient été
expulsé pour des raisons qui étaient un
peu qui semblaient un peu nébuleuse ou
en tout cas pas particulièrement valide
quand on en parlait cette semaine on a
tendu la main la main n'a pas été
agrippé avec où est-ce que ça laisse
madame Anglade
vous avez entendu madame Nicole dire
elle est mal conseillée ça c'est le mot
gentil pour dire et le manquer de
jugement parce que un chef normalement
aurait dû savoir que d'expulser une
députée pour une raison aussi légère
ensuite lui tendre la main sans vraiment
s'excuser
n'allait pas vraiment fonctionner on
n'allait pas ramener madame Nicole pour
avec cette tactique là donc on a manqué
de jugement du côté de Dominique Anglade
et c'est ça qui lui à son les deux
chiffres c'est le fait que ceux qui sont
déjà incertains de savoir si c'est la
bonne personne se disent bon pour une
notion aussi élémentaire que la gestion
de son focus elle l'a vraiment échappé
qu'est-ce que ça va être quand ça va se
corser pour vrai et là des gens qui se
sont mis qui était peut-être assis sur
la clôture et que ce sont mis les
résolument dans le cas de non ça fait
pas continuer des anciens candidats des
anciens présidents du parti donc des
gens qui ont quand même une certaine
influence moi j'ai reçu à mon émission
Jean D'Amour assez député libéral de
Rivière-du-Loup pendant longtemps ancien
président du parti on lui a parlé
elle se présente à une course à la durée
dans un vote de confiance elle doit
obtenir 90% et actuellement elle est
très loin de 90% donc c'est pas tout de
vouloir avoir un vote de confiance
rapidement encore faut-il le gagner est
organisé pour le gagner avoir des
organisateurs il y a beaucoup de compter
à orphelins maintenant qui a plus de
libéraux plus de présidente plus
d'associations
non non c'est tout c'est tout un navire
qui m'a donné
bon
si termos marker à l'époque avait eu
autant de signaux que Dominique englab
depuis deux semaines il serait pas rendu
au vote de confiance qui a perdu parce
qu'il y aurait compris ce qu'elle est
arrivée puis il y a démissionner il
serait épargnés l'humiliation et je vous
rappellerai il l'a perdu en l'absence de
signaux aussi probant alors de penser
qu'on va changer cette situation là
échanger surtout l'image qui est
maintenant vraiment bien installé dans
l'opinion publique de perdante de
Dominique Anglade oublier ça il y a pas
de miracle en politique il y en aura pas
donne l'impression que vous la
s'accrocher comme étant ça peut dur
ça c'est toute la question en fait ça
revient à demander combien de temps
est-ce que Madame Anglade est prête à
souffrir parce que visiblement c'est pas
facile puis ça s'améliore pas on nous
dit en coulisses que justement elle est
très forte très résiliente elle pense
peut-être pouvoir renverser la vapeur
avec la reprise des travaux
parlementaires qui est prévu à la fin du
mois de novembre bonne chance là ce sera
pas facile effectivement de renverser
cette image là et puis c'est comme si
c'était venu un peu symboliser tout ce
que les gens reprochent à Madame Anglade
au sein du Parti libéral depuis qu'elle
a été élu chef le fait qu'elle ait de la
difficulté à gérer le caucus c'est pas
nouveau on en parlait déjà un peu moins
mais sous l'ancienne législature le fait
qu'elle avait fait un peu le vide autour
d'elle c'était avait mis de côté la
déconseillé d'expérience qui était là
depuis longtemps qui peut-être justement
dans ce genre de situation là aurait pu
la conseiller peut-être plus lui faire
valoir que c'était peut-être pas une si
mauvaise idée que ça de nommer madame
Nicoz vice-présidente parce qu'on sait
que les deux femmes s'entendaient pas
très bien ça leur a permis de la
neutraliser pendant les prochaines
années donc maintenant que le train de
la contestation est parti effectivement
ça va être très difficile de l'arrêter
les collègues l'ont bien souligné on
parlait avec des gens ces dernières
semaines on sentait des fois un peu
d'ambivalence d'hésitation le tous ceux
qui hésitaient ont fait leur choix
disent qu'ils vont voter contre le
leadership de Madame anglaise et on a
l'impression que peu importe le moment
visiblement où ça va se tenir ça va pas
une si grande un si grande influence sur
le résultat final parce que dans bien
des circonscriptions effectivement les
deux camps vont partir un peu de zéro là
tellement le parti justement compte plus
de membres il va falloir vendre des
cartes de part et d'autre pour essayer
peut-être de trouver des délégués
favorables à un cas ou l'autre ça va
être toute une aventure madame anglaise
oui durant la campagne on a beaucoup dit
elle était résiliente et tout ça mais
disons que cette semaine on la sentait
déjà un peu plus fatigué éprouvé de tout
ça
mais toujours résolu la photo de son
cocu sur Twitter et prépare la session
on verra comment ça va se dérouler un
autre dossier qui a beaucoup d'attention
cette semaine c'est l'utilisation de la
disposition des rogatoire par le
gouvernement Ford en Ontario c'est pas
la première fois on l'a vu au Québec
aussi ça a été utilisé par
l'administration Legault dans ce cas-ci
on l'a mis dans une loi pour imposer des
conditions de travail aux employés du
secteur de l'éducation en Ontario
chanteur je commence avec vous qu'est-ce
que ça change au débat que ça a été
utilisé dans cette dans ces
circonstances là qu'est-ce que ça fait
Ottawa ça change la donne de toutes
sortes de façon la première façon dont
ça change la donne c'est que le
mouvement syndical canadien toute
province confondues considère que ce que
Monsieur Ford a fait en soustrayant une
noix de retour au travail de
l'application de la Charte des droits
c'est une menace existentielle au
processus de négociation collective et
aux droits de grève ça s'était jamais
produit au Canada et on a souvent envoyé
des grévistes ou empêcher des gens de
faire la grève avec des lois mais on n'a
jamais suspendu
les droits syndicaux et les droits
d'association qui sont contenus dans un
short des droits donc mobilisation cette
mobilisation là ça amène notamment le
NPD à faire pression beaucoup plus
vigoureusement sur le gouvernement du
système Trudeau pour qu'ils soient plus
proactif dans le dossier de
l'utilisation ou de la bonne ou mauvaise
utilisation de la clause de dérogation
le gouvernement Justin Trudeau avait
comme position jusqu'à présent parce que
le débat était déjà commencé à cause de
la loi 21 de la loi 96 au Québec et de
l'utilisation de la clause de façon
préventive dans les deux cas elle avait
dit on va laisser les choses se passer
et faire
son leur chemin dans le système de
justice au Québec et on va intervenir en
cours suprême pour donner notre point de
vue là dessus
je crois que maintenant on va assister à
un virage pourquoi parce que
politiquement pour le gouvernement
Justin Trudeau c'est ou bien beaucoup
plus attirant ou bien beaucoup plus
facile en tout cas moins difficile de
dire on va y aller nous en cours suprême
on va poser la question on va accélérer
l'obtention d'une réponse maintenant
qu'on parle de droit syndicaux que quand
c'était une question qui touchait des
lois identitaires au Québec alors je
serai pas étonné moins que une journée
dans les prochaines semaines monsieur
Trudeau monsieur la médecine ministre de
justice nous annonce qui vont poser une
série de questions à la Cour suprême sur
la bonne ou la moins bonne utilisation
de la clause d'un absent avec l'idée que
la Cour peut-être il y a pas de garantie
là mais que la Cour peut-être donne une
réponse qui va dans le sens de
d'encadrer davantage l'utilisation de
cette loi de la réponse mais c'est sûr
qu'il y a un prétexte pour poser la
question à l'acte qu'est-ce que ça
change pour vous
ça pourrait changer beaucoup de choses
parce que comme les viennent de le dire
Chantal on utilise le cadre ontarien
probablement parce que je suis assez
d'accord avec Chantal je pense que
Ottawa va se trouver de manière de faire
un renvoi à la course suprême rapidement
pour pouvoir éclaircir ce dossier là on
utilise le cadre ontarien mais il va
s'appliquer ailleurs ce cadre-là si la
course suprême se prononce décide
d'encadrer l'utilisation préventive la
clause de la clause dérogatoire ou de la
disposition des relations ça va toucher
les autres provinces ça va toucher le
Québec aussi où on l'a déjà utilisé à
plusieurs reprises de manière préventive
cette disposition là aussi récemment que
la loi 21 sur la laïcité loi 96 sur la
réforme de l'achat de la langue
française puis on l'utilisait d'autres
moments et on sent Ottawa déjà qu'on
était agacé par cette utilisation là
mais le cadre était peut-être trop
complexe juste la notion de dialogue
entre le judiciaire le législatif
l'exécutif on n'aime pas beaucoup qu'on
peut s'utiliser cette clause là de
manière préventive là si on l'a plus
certaines provinces commencent à
l'appliquer
des relations de travail écoutez le
médecin dans une loi alors que la grève
n'est même pas déclenchée encore du côté
des employés de soutien des écoles en
Ontario on se dit ça va très très loin
alors je comprends le milieu syndical
les deux bouts dans son café puis de
vouloir encadrer ça mais le résultat
c'est qu'on va encadrer peut-être pas
mal plus large que les relations de
travail si la course prenne se prononce
là-dessus on vient d'ouvrir toute une
boîte de Pandore du côté de dogford je
sais pas si on l'avait calculé j'en
doute mais on vient d'ouvrir tout un
débat là c'est pas un niveau de retour
au travail on impose des conditions de
travail Hugo est-ce qu'on trouve ça il
nous reste une quarantaine de secondes
est-ce qu'on sauve 25 centimes à Québec
oui absolument parce que le recours à la
disposition des radiations ça fait
partie un peu de la tirade nationaliste
sans que la CAQ effectivement a mis de
l'avant ces dernières années Alec
mentionné ces deux exemples de la loi 21
et 96 et donc on fait valoir qu'on a
utilisé la disposition dans ces deux
collègues justement pour préserver des
droits collectifs de la nation
québécoise et donc c'était pas pour des
raisons triviales pour véritablement des
raisons fondamentales et là de voir la
course suprême possiblement venir
baliser ça bah ça peut être tout un
casse-tête en même temps il faut voir la
véritable façon de s'en débarrasser si
c'est ça que le gouvernement fédéral
souhaite ou de baliser ce serait d'y
aller d'un amendement constitutionnel on
a l'impression évidemment qu'on essaie
de trouver une façon oui mais il y a pas
d'appui pour ça ben non effectivement
donc on essaie d'y aller
impossible certainement mais là où je
vais en venir c'est que le gouvernement
du Québec voit d'un mauvais œil
justement une façon indirecte d'essayer
de neutraliser cette clause là justement
alors que fait partie de la Constitution
dans l'état actuel des choses puis
justement qu'on voulait en faire un
usage un peu plus grand sans doute au
cours des prochaines années
à cause de ce que hugozy c'est parce que
si Monsieur Trudeau appelé ses meilleurs
amis la première ministre le Premier
ministre l'Ontario François Legault les
convoqués une conférence
constitutionnelle en leur disant mes
amis on va se débarrasser de la clause
nonobstant on va demander la
Constitution la rencontre dure pas
longtemps pas besoin de de d'arrêter les
moteurs des avions des premiers
ministres la demi-heure
il y a pas d'appui provincial
suffisant pour amender la Constitution
pour en soustraire la clause d'un
instant bon commençons par voir ça va
effectivement se ramasser devant la Cour
suprême mais tout le monde semble assez
convaincu qu'on s'en va vers ça on va
reparler probablement Alex Chantal Hugo
merci d'avoir été des nôtres à la
semaine prochaine au revoir merci au
revoir